Now this is kind of a funny question with
some funny answers, and so depending on
your thinking, you might picked any of
these answers. I personally though, think
that the best answer is the third one, to
count them. If the teacher counts her
students before they leave and then counts
them at different points during their time
at the zoo, she can know pretty easily
whether or not they are all sticking
together. Congratulations on completing
your first quiz of the class whether you
picked the same answer as I did or not.
You'll encounter many quizzes like this
throughout the rest of the course.
Although they probably won't all be as
silly as this one. But please remember
that even as we dig deeper into algebra,
the point of all of these quizzes will be
for you to check if you understand the
material. Just give each question some
thought and if you're have trouble
choosing an answer, rewatch the video or
couple of videos preceding the quiz. If
you get a question right that's awesome
and if you miss one that's not a big deal
at all. Just try it again and submit your
new answer. You can redo each question as
many times as you need to. We want you to
do whatever you need to do to really
understand the material.